[Música]
la suma de voluntades hace la diferencia
hola soy mariana y estoy muy contenta de
estar aquí el día de hoy con ustedes
porque quiero platicarles el significado
y la relevancia que ha tenido en mi
entender como sumando voluntades podemos
hacer una diferencia
trabajé varios años en una fundación
donde teníamos a niños y niñas con
discapacidad y la historia de cómo se
forma me inspira mucho y me hace sentido
con lo que les quiero platicar su
fundador fernando landeros tuvo un sueño
porque tuvo un encuentro con una persona
que el impacto de tal manera que
encontró el sentido de su vida esta
persona es el máximo ejemplo de entrega
y de amor al prójimo y a los demás y
cuando él ve esa satisfacción de poder
ayudar a los demás él decide que tiene
que ser algo grande por los niños pero
él sabe que solo no lo puede hacer pero
tiene que llegar a los corazones de
muchísimas y muchísimas personas y hacer
que crean en su sueño y que crean en él
cuando lo logra el día de hoy hoy tiene
una de las fundaciones más grandes de
todo méxico 25 centros a lo largo del
país ayudando a miles y miles de niños
con discapacidad cáncer y autismo pero
le queda claro esto no lo logra sólo él
lo logra gracias a que muchos nos
sumamos
y pusimos nuestro esfuerzo trabajamos
junto con él para llegar a esto
cuando estaba preparando la plática y
veía cómo poderles transmitir este amor
esta pasión que sentimos cuando ayudamos
a los demás se me vino en mente una
película que se llama cadena de favores
me imagino que ya la vieron y si no se
las voy a platicar es un niño que en su
clase de ciencias sociales la maestra lo
cuestiona y le dice qué esperas del
mundo o el mundo que espera de ti
entonces él trata de encontrar como
respuesta a este cuestionamiento y dice
sabes que tengo que hacer algo grande
tengo que hacer lo que el profesor
quiere es que nosotros busquemos cómo
cambiar este mundo pero qué hago usaba
su casa encuentra un indigente se lo
lleva y le da de comer y él dice no pues
yo puedo ayudar una persona a la mejor 2
a la mejor 3 pero aquí va a quedar me
ayuda y buena es muy bueno no que esté
malo pero él quiere realmente hacer algo
más grande y sabe que solo no lo puede
hacer entonces queda un sistema donde él
ayuda a una persona y esta persona tiene
que ayudar a tres y esto a otras tres y
se va multiplica
la ayuda entonces él se da cuenta el
impacto que tiene cuando sumamos
voluntades y corazones para llegar a un
solo objetivo
se me figura como las hormiguitas que
todos trabajamos para un mismo fin y que
trabajemos juntas y unidas para entre
todos llegar a un punto ustedes han
visto las hormigas que son disciplinadas
y que agarran las cosas entre todos les
digo yo no he visto que la hormiga quite
la otra hormiga para llegar primero
llega con el pedazo de pan y se va
corriendo
ella saben la importancia que tenemos
cada uno y que si cada quien hace lo que
le toca podemos llegar a un objetivo al
final a lograr algo
como cuando hay un desastre natural se
fijan todos nos unimos y empezamos a
juntar la ropa la comida los víveres
todos todos unidos y ahí es donde vemos
la capacidad que tenemos como seres
humanos de empatizar con el dolor ajeno'
y ser capaces de ayudar pero porque no
amas en un desastre natural porque no
siempre ayudar porque no estar en
nuestra parte de nuestra cultura de
nuestro ser el amor al prójimo y el
buscar la manera de poder ayudarlo y de
poder impactar y sabiendo que si nos
unimos que si entre todos llegamos un
punto podemos lograr cosas más grandes
también podemos trabajar solos podemos
ayudar podemos hacer un bien pero la
idea es sumarnos y poder impactar más
imagínense un globo y que lo pinchan con
un clavito y se revienta qué pasa
si este globo lo ponemos en una cama de
clavito de agujas y lapacho ramos yo
pensaría pues va a explotar más porque
tiene muchos clavitos y no la física nos
dice que la presión ejercida entre
varios puntos se comparte y es menos
qué pasa con nosotros y nosotros podemos
compartir la responsabilidad de poder
hacer algo y cambiar a nuestro mundo la
presión sería menos no una sola persona
que tuvo un sueño que creo que podía
hacer algo por los niños lo hizo solo
comparte la responsabilidad con todos y
todos juntos podemos llegar esa presión
y no reventar uno solo
que les quiero transmitir el día de hoy
que la suma de voluntades puede hacer
una diferencia
se preguntarán pero como me puedo sumar
o qué puedo hacer cómo puedo ayudar hay
tantas y tantas causas que necesitan
manos que se sumen para hacerlas grandes
imagínense que el día de hoy ustedes se
van con la convicción de buscar que me
que me motiva que causa puedo encontrar
donde puedo yo ayudar donde me puedo
sumar habrá quienes dicen bueno a mí me
gusta el planeta y quiero reciclar y
quiero limpiar playas y quiero salvar
tortugas habrá quienes dicen a mí me
gustan los niños quiero ayudar a niños
con discapacidad a un asilo hay tanto
hay tantas cosas que necesitan que nos
sumemos y no hay esfuerzo pequeño porque
todo suma y el tiempo y qué puedo hacer
desde donar mi ropa desde unirnos en
oración por todos desde poder donar mi
tiempo que siempre les digo lo más
difícil que hay es donar el tiempo
porque yo puedo dedicar mi semana una
hora diez minutos un día o toda una vida
pero ese tiempo es esa convicción esa
entrega que vamos a hacer por los demás
y eso es muy muy difícil pero cuando lo
hacemos y sentimos esa satisfacción de
ver qué
tiene un sentido más así que puedo
llegar a ayudar a los demás para mí la
gratitud es un valor muy importante y
cuando nosotros podemos dar gracias por
todo lo que tenemos a través de
compartir los demás es una manera
agradecer por quiénes somos y por lo que
tenemos
cuando vemos las redes cuando vemos las
pláticas con los demás cuando estamos
viendo nuestro ambiente que predomina
platicamos de cosas positivas o que
predomina
lo negativo porque a veces es lo que más
vende y en las redes vemos muchísimos
retos muchísimas cosas sin sentido y a
veces hasta peligrosas porque no es una
moda ayudar porque no podemos tener en
redes sociales porque no podemos
comunicar con los demás
este amor decir vamos a hacer algo todos
juntos hoy nos vamos a reunir y en esta
reunión vamos a poner un granito de
arena para ayudar a los demás crear algo
positivo y llenar a lo mejor también
nuestro entorno de cosas positivas y una
vez vi un reto que sí se hizo viral y
que era en la venta de una cubeta de
agua fría recaudó mucho dinero pero fue
una vez porque no hacer de esto una
constante porque no buscar el poder
impactar y llegar más allá
ojalá que puedan encontrar en su vida
una persona que los motive y que
encuentren ese sentido y ojalá ese
sentido tenga que ver con la ayuda de
los demás con entregarnos con poquito
con mucho con lo que tengamos pero
podamos impactar este mundo con algo
mejor porque estoy convencida que si
todos tenemos un espíritu y una cultura
de ayuda y de amor al prójimo no dejamos
espacio para cosas negativas que podemos
ser una mejor persona un mejor país una
mejor sociedad
ojalá que a ustedes como a mí les haga
mucho sentido el entender que sumando
voluntades podemos lograr hacer una gran
gran diferencia muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]